تدمير المكتبات ومحو الارث الثقافي
لاوكرانيا كان الجزء الرئيسي من
استراتيجيه روسيا عندما بدات عمليتها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا من اجل القضاء على
الهويه الاوكرانيه والقضاء على اي انتماء
وطني للاوكرانيين وفقه ما كشفت صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه تدور معظم الحروب
حول من سيحدد المستقبل والحرب الاوكرانيه
هي صراع حول من سيحدد الماضي تقول ايضا
الصحيفه البريطانيه التي كشفت ان قبل
ثلاثه ايام من اندلاع الحرف اوكرانيا قدم
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتن ما يرقى الى
مستوى اطروحه تاريخيه كاعلاني حرب وكانت
حجته انا اوكرانيا كانت خيالا خلقته روسيا
بالكامل من دون التقاليد المستقره للدوله
الحقيقيه ولكن الرئيس الاوكراني فولو دي
ميرسي رد عليه بان الهويه الاوكرانيه
موجوده وهي ذات طبيعه اوروبيه ومنذ بدايه
بتحارب استهدفت روسيا المكتبات الاوكرانيه
وابرزها ارشيف الدوله في تشارياف الذي
يحتوي على معلومات حساسه حول قمع الحقد
سوفيتيه التي اراد الروس محوها من السجل
التاريخي
[موسيقى]